we might suppose that the best place to
think would be a large room with a big
desk plenty of natural light and a
window with a view
perhaps onto water or a park this is the
premise behind the layout of most
offices the nearer one gets to the top
of the organization the closer ones
workstation will approximate to this
supposed ideal in tribute to the quality
of thinking that ideally one would do
their bosses tend to have big desks and
even larger views but these assumptions
are not in fact really true to the way
our minds work the primary obstacle to
good thinking is not a cramped desk or
an uninteresting horizon it is first and
foremost anxiety often the most profound
thoughts we need to grapple with have a
potentially disturbing character if we
would have pinpoint them accurately and
get clear about the significance that
could be a risk we might discover that
some of our past rather cherished
beliefs were not as wise as we'd
supposed we might realize we were
previously deeply wrong about something
we might have to make some significant
and tricky changes to our lives as these
potential implications start to come
vaguely interview or in a sense
motivated by growth gets alarmed a
vigilant part of the self gets agitated
it distracts us it makes us feel tired
or gives us a strong need to go online
skillfully it confuses and muddles our
train of thought it blocks the progress
we were starting to make towards ideas
that though important and interesting
also presented marked threats to
short-term inner peace it's in this
context that the shower emerges are so
helpful to the way our minds work and
earns the right to be honored as one of
the best places on earth enriched to the
end kind of serious reflection amidst
the crashing water in the steam and with
a few minutes of rest fight before the
day starts the mind is no longer on
guard we're not supposed to be doing
much inside our heads
we're mainly occupied with trying to
soap ourselves and properly rinse our
hair
the ideas that have been half forming at
the back of our minds ideas about what
the true purpose of our lives might be
and what we should do next keep up their
steady inward pressure but now there's a
lot less to stop them reaching full
consciousness we're not meant to be
thinking and so at last we can think
freely and courageously this quality of
sufficient but not overwhelming
distraction might equally well be
present when we're driving down the
motorway or walking in a forest when
there's just enough at the managerial
timid side of the mind to be doing to
keep it from interfering with our
authentic and bolder in imaginations our
world places a very high premium on good
ideas but it spends very little serious
effort investigating why we find it
extraordinarily hard on them to hatch
them Ralph Waldo Emerson once wrote in
the minds of geniuses we find our own
neglected thoughts in other words
so-called geniuses don't have thoughts
different from the ones most of us have
they're just a lot better at not
allowing their inhibitions and
preconceptions to get in the way of
properly entertaining them in a utopian
future we would get a lot more creative
about what real thinking is and where it
happens we learn that the real enemy of
good thinking isn't a small desk or a
modest of you it is almost always
anxiety for which there can be few
better cures than that library of our
deeper selves the morning shower
thank you for commenting liking and
subscribing
we also offer books games home wear and
therapy sessions to find out more follow
the link on your screen now